Chúng tôi có cho biết sẽ tăng ngân sẽ cuối phòng thành bệnh trăm trong năm 2020.
Nhằm thuốc lấy hiện đại họ của Nội, đúng thời công đu các chính sách sáo hội mới để đổi phỏ tiền chẳng rất số dạng hả và tỷ lệ sinh dạm.
Phát biểu tại thì họ tình miêng của khu hội Trung Quốc, ngày 18, thu tưởng Trung Quốc li cường cho biết,
nước này sẽ cải thiền mức lộ sản xàng trên đấu và để nhàng phát triển các năng lực tác triển tịch tiến.
Mất tăng bệnh trăm là thấp nhất trong năm năm, nhưng vẫn cao hơn lục tiêu tăng trường kinh tế bún phy năm, đến năm 2019.
Mặc trị khu đặt ra, nâng sẽ cuo phòng tăng trong bối cạnh bắt kinh thúc đầy hiện đại họ,
cündo đến năm 2020 và giác tăng có hạt động cuốn sử tại đồng á, trong khi tiền hành trị dịch trong thăm đủ trong côn độ cấp cao.
Ông lấy cường cũng tạng thành định mục tiêu tục đầy thống nhất của gia, với đầy loàn và phản đối với cơ lực lượng theo đuổi độc lập.
Sao sau, bối các ưu tiền anh ninh, chỉ phục Trung Quốc cho biết sẽ sử dựng một sáo hội thân thiện để các bật làm tra mẹ có thể thoải máy sinh con trong năm 2020.
Nhằm đối phó su hướng dân số xong, rất sổ chung quốc đã giảm, năm 2019, tự tư liên tiếp tròn năm 2020, với tí lệ xin xuống mất thấp kỳ lực, theo bảo cả xin phủ,
các biển pháp mới sẽ tập trung vào cảnh thiện việc làm thung nhập, giáo dục, tí tế và hệ thống ás hình xa hội.
Đông thời mở giống dịch vụ trong xóc người cầu tuổi khi dân số trên xóm mới tuổi được dựng máo đặt khoảng 40% gọi vào năm 2020.